Hi Guys.
So,
um,
we're going to talk about the brain
today.
Last lecture I talked to you a little
bit about construct validation and what
it means to measure something.
And so we're gonna take a bit of a
detour.
So I told you about measurement problems
last time.
If you do your measurement properly in
psychometrics,
if you're studying personality,
if you're studying individual
differences,
there are roughly six things that you
can discover and they can be broken up
in different ways.
That's the big five model,
extroversion and neuroticism,
agreeableness,
conscientiousness,
openness,
and they can be subdivided as you should
know,
because it principal,
you've read the paper,
the sub divided them into 10 half turns
out to be quite useful.
But for now we'll just presume that
there are five.
And then the other factor of human
function that's pretty easy to derive
and measure his Iq.
Now,
Iq likely nests under openness because
openness looks like it's something
roughly like intellect,
which has interest in ideas,
but it,
that's probably an ability with ideas.
But that's probably measured better by
an Iq test.
So if I ask you how smart you are and
you say you're pretty smart,
that would give you a relatively high
score on the intellect scale.
But if I tested your Iq,
I will get a better measure than not.
So in some sense,
Iq nests inside the big five model,
but you can think about it as a separate
thing and I think it's reasonable to do
that.
So you know,
it depends on what you're up to
fundamentally.
Now when the big five was first
invented,
invented or discovered,
depending on how you look at it,
as I mentioned briefly as well,
it was brute force statistics basically.
So the idea behind the big five is that
the,
uh,
it's called the lexical hypothesis and
Alexa Co hypothesis is that because
human traits are so important to us
because we want to understand ourselves,
and perhaps even more importantly,
we want to understand other people.
And because we have language,
there's a reasonable probability that
we've encapsulated the structure of
human personality within our language.
And so if you analyze the language
linguistic representations properly,
then perhaps you can extract out the
central personality features.
And that's basically what the lexical
hypothesis is and it,
it's important to know the lexical
hypothesis and it's a bit more
sophisticated than that because it
basically presumes that you can extract
out route valid information about
personality from adjectives,
descriptive adjectives from phrases and
from questions,
and you'll get the same basic
dimensional structure regardless of
which of those techniques you use.
And that turns out to be true for all
intents and purposes.
Now,
the lexical hypothesis depends on its
validity,
depends for its validity on the initial
claim.
That personality is accurately
represented within the structure of
language.
And so one of the things I would say is
that there's a week big five hypothesis
and a strong,
big five hypothesis.
Okay.
The week big five hypothesis is that in
so far as you use language to describe
personality,
personality has a five factor structure
that's reliably extractable.
Now,
the strong,
Big Five theory is that no,
no personality has a fight factor
structure and it's accurately
represented in language.
But when you pull out the structure from
language,
what you're pulling out is actually
representative of genuine personality.
Now,
the week hypothesis is I would say it's
established and it's worth knowing
because what it,
what it means is that if you invent a
questionnaire that has anything to do
with self description,
it might be self description at multiple
different levels of analysis,
um,
like values for example.
And instead of just adjectives or
attitudes instead of just adjectives.
I mean these categories are sort of of
uh,
unclear.
What's the difference between your
attitude and your temperament?
Well,
you know,
it's usually defined by the sentence
that you use the words in,
right?
You extract out the words,
they sort of stand there alone.
They don't,
it's very difficult to clarify their
meaning.
Anyways,
the lexical hypothesis I think is one of
the most well established.
It's one of the most well validated
claims in psychology.
I think it might be the most validated
claim apart from maybe the work that is
extracted Iq out from cognitive
questions.
And uh,
basically it was brute force statistics.
You know,
people develop different lists of
adjectives and you can complain in some
ways about how they did it and we'll
talk about that later.
But because they tried to throw out the
evaluative words,
like good and evil,
for example,
those aren't in the big five.
Um,
so they tried to only use adjectives
that didn't necessarily seem to be like
highly or like valued or devalued.
So introvert and extrovert,
while they're opposites,
but you know,
is it better to be an introvert?
It's better to be the extroverts like,
well,
it's not obvious.
So those were all the words that cover
that dimension can be kept in because
there's no value judgements associated
with it.
And the originators of the big five
theory wanted to keep it as free of
values as possible.
Now that's already a hypothesis,
right?
It's a hypothesis that you can come up
with an accurate description of human
personality,
even if you eliminate all the words that
have to do that are clearly valence
east.
And,
uh,
we did an experiment here a while back
that was pretty interesting.
Um,
we got hold of our data set of
descriptive adjectives and we put all
the evaluative words back in,
so,
you know,
like nasty and horrible and awkward and
uh,
cruel.
And,
um,
and then the good words as well,
you know,
moral,
pleasant,
uplifting,
all of those things.
And,
and we had people rate people they liked
and people they didn't like using that
expanded list.
And we got a real archetype in some
sense of the hateable person.
And a tremendous number of the words
that were used came from the evaluative
dimension.
So I think that when you throw out the
evaluative words,
you actually throw out a lot of what
people actually use.
Descriptive words to describe.
Because you know,
when you like someone or don't like
someone if someone's likable or
unlikable,
that's pretty important phenomena.
You know what I mean?
You hang around the people you like
generally speaking and you don't
associate with the people you don't
like.
So it's a fundamental choice.
But we all talk about that later because
there's reasons that happened and the
reasons were valid and it's not that
easy to fix it.
And besides that,
the standard five factor model has all
sorts of utility.
So,
but you need to know what its strengths
are and its limitations are.
Now hypothetically,
what you knew to draw out the five
factor model is you take,
imagine the sec of all descriptive
adjectives.
Okay.
And then you take a random sample of
those descriptive adjectives so that
it's not biased.
You don't have to use all of them
because you know,
if you ask someone to describe
themselves on a questionnaire using all
the adjectives we have that describe
personality,
they'd be there for like a day.
And so that's not very efficient.
And so you want to take a random sample,
maybe you only sample the words that
people are most likely to use.
So for example,
if you go online,
you'll find that there are word
frequency tables,
you know,
and most of your language,
most of the about 500 words covers about
80% of what you say.
So you know,
and I don't remember what the lexicon of
the typical person is,
I,
I think it's in the neighborhood of
3,500 words,
but that might be wrong,
but there's like 750,000 words in the
English language know.
It's an omnivorous language.
It just pulled words in from all over.
And so you hardly use any of those
words,
you know,
and there's ones that are used
extraordinarily in frequently.
So what you could do is you could look
at the total set of adjectives and then
you could pull out,
you know,
identify the ones,
the ones that are used,
you know,
the thousand most frequently used words
and that probably cover 95% of the
territory.
And then you could pick out random set
of a hundred and you could administer it
to people and then you can factor it,
analyze it,
you administered it to lots of people,
then you factor analyze it and you get
five relatively clear and stable
factors.
And the most,
the one that comes out first,
so it's,
it's the dominant factor in some sense
or the easiest to measure are maybe the
best representative language or
something like that.
It's extroversion versus introversion.
And extroversion is a positive emotion
dimension and it's associated with
enthusiasm and assertiveness and
assertive people will say they'll
dominate the conversation with language
or they'll while back basically that's
about the right way to think about it.
I'm enthusiastic people,
they're up for anything.
You know,
they're the ones that are always smiling
and telling jokes and having parties and
that sort of thing.
And generally extroverts really liked to
be around people,
so they're happy.
They're gregarious,
they're assertive,
they're enthusiastic,
they're noisy,
they blink bore than introverts.
Now why that is,
I have no idea.
But apparently they do.
So if you notice something blinking a
lot,
you can assume that they're extroverts.
Um,
if they're not conscientious,
like you know,
there's this idea of people being
impulsive.
It's very badly defined terms.
So when you hear a psychologist talking
about impulsivity,
the first thing you could realize is
they don't know.
You don't know what the hell they're
talking about because probably there's
no such thing as impulsivity.
But extroverted people who are not very
conscientious tend to,
that's one of the things that you might
think about as associated with
impulsivity.
There's all sorts of other things though
too.
So,
um,
okay,
so there's a positive emotion dimension
and that's extroversion.
And there's negative emotion,
emotion,
dimension,
and that's neuroticism and neurotic.
Neuroticism seems to break down into
something like withdrawal and volatility
and volatile people are touching.
So you know they'll,
they'll react quite a lot if something
negative happens.
So if you've teased it and they might
get upset or if you start fighting with
them and that sort of provocative way
instead of sort of calming everything
down,
they will just ramp it up.
And if there's two of you that are
volatile and you're having a
conversation and the conversation goes a
little bit,
you know,
into unpleasant territory,
you can really get each other going.
So yes,
like in term of south beach and I can
turn those days both.
Oh,
both.
Yeah.
I mean that's part of the problem with
using the word emotion because you know,
is an emotion and internal state or a
set of behaviors.
And the answer to that is as far as we
can tell,
it's both.
So now
I'm going to start talking about
extroversion and neuroticism.
And part of the reason for that is
because I think the evidence for the
relationship between those traits and
the way the brain functions functions is
in some sense the clearest.
Now you remember the baby five were
extracted out using statistical
procedures,
right?
So there's no reason to assume
necessarily that the traits would bear
any straight forward relationship to
brain function because they didn't,
they weren't derived from analysis of
brain function,
at least not directly they were at,
they were extracted from analysis of
linguistic representations of other
peoples and your own behavior.
But it turns out that there's quite a
concordance between certain elements of
neuropsychological theory and deposit of
Edom and negative emotional traits,
extroversion and neuroticism.
And so what I'm going to do today is I'm
gonna,
I'm gonna,
I'm going to talk to you about how
positive and negative emotion are,
are,
um,
instantiated in some sense
neurologically.
But I'm going to put that in a,
in a broader picture of brain function
because,
well,
because first of all,
why not?
And second,
because a lot of the things I'm going to
tell you about the brain today,
we'll sort of retroactively shed light
on some of the clinical theories that
we've already talked about.
So,
so which is nice,
you know,
because when it,
one of the ways that you find out if
something is true,
and this is something we also talked
about during the last lecture,
is that it manifests itself even when
you use different measurement
techniques.
And so he had this statistical
derivation,
you know,
which basically took place.
It really started to accelerate,
I would say first in the 1960s and then
in the 1980s it made a big comeback in
the 1980s but paralleling not were
theories of brain development and they
weren't really that the scientists that
were doing the one sort of research
really work communicating with the
scientists that were doing the other
kind of research.
So they were methodologically separate.
They use different techniques as well,
but they weren't talking back and forth
much and they were using different
measurement techniques.
So if they both come up with the same
thing,
then you think,
oh well there's probably something to
that because you know the sighted people
discovered that down there.
People who could hear discovered it.
It's,
it's the same kind of idea.
So,
and you know,
this has been worked out in a fair bit
of detail over the last
30 years really.
And so,
um,
the,
the papers that you're supposed to read
with this,
they're difficult papers.
Uh,
I believe you're reading gray,
which is a model of the limbic system
and Basal Ganglia applications to
anxiety and schizophrenia.
Um,
um,
I think you have goals and behavior.
That's the Carbon Shire paper.
I put the Swanson paper in as optional.
That's cerebral hemisphere regulation of
motivated behavior.
That is a tough paper and so is the gray
paper and it's part of it because of
these guys,
both of them graze paper is that is a
distillation of a very,
very thick book that's very,
very difficult.
And that's been written twice.
It was published first in 1982 and then
again in 1999.
It's a brilliant book.
It's had a tremendous impact on
psychology.
Gray was one of those people who he was
so damn smart.
It's just painful.
You know what I mean?
His reference list,
I don't know how many papers are in his
reference lists,
like 2001 of the really weird things
about gray that makes him stand out
among scientist is he actually read all
those papers and more than that he
understood them.
And so that's really something.
And so gray's book on anxiety,
um,
he,
he did a lot of work with animal
behavior.
I'll tell you if you want like solid
psychological information about how the
brain works,
the people you pay attention to are the
animal,
the,
the people who are studying animal
behavior and animal grades,
they know what they're doing there.
So methodologically careful,
they're very,
very reliable and the human
neuropsychologists and the people who
use pet scanners and Mris and all that
thing,
there are way,
way,
way behind the animal researchers
because the animal researchers can just
get in there at a lot higher resolution
and they can do much more stringent
experiments and they tend to be more
methodological,
careful and more scientifically minded.
So anyways,
the grade book is a brilliant book.
It's very,
it took me like four months to read that
damn book and I mean I was,
I really had to take it apart because he
probably poured 30 years of work into
it,
something like that.
And like he worked a lot in 30 years.
You know,
he did a lot of experimentation and he
read a lot.
And so he built a bottle of the,
of the brain's function that was based
on,
partly on Russian neuropsychology,
partly on cybernetic theory,
hardly on animal behavior,
partly on neuropsychopharmacology.
And so that's the study of how drugs
affect behavior and cognition and then
partly partly from a higher order
conceptual perspective.
And then he stacked all those things up,
one on top of the other to make sure
that the picture was the same at every
single level of analysis.
It's absolutely brilliant.
Where can it took the social
psychologists?
Like they already started thinking about
gray,
although he published his book in 1982
they probably started thinking about
great,
seriously in about 2005 so it took 23
years for his book to start to make its
widescale entrance into the more general
psychological community.
And anyways,
and so you're going to read this paper,
which is a model of the limbic system
and Basal Ganglia.
And it's a distillate,
it's 30 years were distilled into the
book and then that was distilled into
this paper.
So you know,
it's rough going.
And then the Swanson paper,
he's another guy,
same kind of guy.
He's a developmental neuro anatomist.
And if you're really interested in
psychology,
I would really recommend reading those
papers because like they're hard going.
But if you get it,
you,
you have this substrata of knowledge
underneath you that's really from,
and I rated like Swanson's paper,
the guy's a genius.
And what's so cool about Swanson's paper
is that if you talk to human
neuropsychologists,
you'll find that their bias towards the
cerebral cortex,
and there's sort of,
I think there's sort of an
anthropomorphic pride that goes along
with that.
It's like,
well,
how are we different from animals?
Well,
you know,
we've got thumbs and nuts,
great,
hooray for the thumbs and we stand up,
right?
But if you look at us neurologically,
the big differences that we have this
tremendously expanded cerebral cortex,
especially the prefrontal cortex.
And so then people think,
well,
because you know,
that's one of the things that
differentiates from animals and it's
relatively evolutionarily modern because
the human brain really,
really developed rapidly over the last 2
million years that it's like king of the
brain in some sense.
And uh,
it's the place where all the complicated
things happen.
And that's just not right.
Because like breathing,
that's complicated.
That's why you don't get to control it
voluntarily and keeping your heart
going.
That's complicated too.
And so you don't get to have a decision
about that.
Your brain has made that automatic like
millions of years ago because there's
just no way you're going to get
voluntary control over something that's
that vital,
you know?
So assuming that newer brain areas do
more complex things is in some ways I
think that's actually precisely
backwards.
It's the old brain areas that have been
around for,
you know,
a hundred a hundred million years.
Those damn things are smart and that's
why they've survived for so long and why
they're distributed and into so many
different species.
You know,
like you,
your brain is somewhat like a lobster's
brain.
It's a lot like a mouse brain and it's a
lot like a rat brain and you might
think,
well,
the rapper and isn't a very good model
of a human brain because after all their
rats,
but one thing I can tell you is that a
rat brain is a way better model of a
human brain.
Then your model of a human brain is a
model of the human brain.
You know what I mean?
It's like people think of the brain
while they have a don't be modeled.
Use a rack as an example.
Of course it's,
it's often some ways cause rats can't
talk for example,
but there are so many levels of analysis
where you,
you might as well be Iraq,
you know,
technically speaking,
the neuro pharmacology for example,
is very,
very similar.
The function of the neurotransmitters,
the basic anatomy of the structures,
like there's a tremendous amount of of
overlap.
And so you might as well go for the
commonalities among brains before you
focusing on the differences because in
some sense that way you get the basic
architecture right now.
Now one of the things that's really
interesting about Swanson,
and this makes it,
and he's not a neuropsychologist and
he's not really even a psychologist.
He's a developmental neuro anatomist.
And so there's lots of ways of piecing
of chopping up the brain,
you know,
to look at it because it's a really
complicated thing.
It's like saying,
well how many ways can you divide up a
city to analyze it?
Well,
there's,
there's endless numbers of ways that you
can divide up a city to look at it.
And there's,
it's the same with the brain,
you know,
because it's,
it's infinitely sub dividable in some
sense,
certainly all the way down to the
molecular structures.
And then even at higher order levels,
you know,
because it's so complex and it's
hierarchically structured,
you can just divide it up in all sorts
of different ways.
And so at higher levels of resolution,
there isn't even that much agreement on
how the name,
the parts.
Now what the developmental neuro
anatomist do is that they look at how
the brain develops in utero over time.
So he,
cause it's a developing thing that sort
of unfolds like a flower unfolds,
you know,
and you can track how the,
which part of the early brain turns into
the later brain.
And so you can get some sense of the
like,
it's like an evolutionary tree.
You know,
if these three parts grew out of this
part,
then you can assume that there's some
commonality between them.
And that can also help you figure out
how to divide up the brain.
And so that's one of the things that
Swanson does.
But the other thing he does,
which I really liked,
is that instead of looking at the brain
from the top down,
which is what human neuropsychologists
tend to do because they concentrate on
say language and you know,
higher order cognitive functions,
which we think of as complex,
but you think they're not that damn
complex.
You know,
like a computer can can do mathematics
so much better than you that there's not
even any comparison.
You know,
and it won't be very long before.
A lot of the things that,
that we think of as abstract cognition
are things that computers are going to
be able to do,
right?
They just want to go tournament for
example.
And the computers are now better.
Even your pc is better at playing chess
than probably anyone in this room.
And the really high end computers are
better at playing chess that anyone who,
who lives and so computers are catching
up damn fast,
but you'll notice that they don't do
things like bus tables in restaurants
because it turns out that's really hard.
You know,
when you think about it,
it's hard.
You know,
you're carrying different size loads all
the time.
You have to interact socially with
people properly.
You have to stay the hell out of the
way.
You have to exactly time when you're
going to come to the table,
you know you have to,
you have to move extraordinarily
efficiently,
especially as the place gets busy.
You know,
there's a lot of demands on you to do
that job effectively.
And you know,
we think about it as a low end job,
but it's not automated.
The low end jobs are the ones that are
going to be automated first.
And it's not obvious that they're going
to be the things that we associated with
low end labor.
You know,
it's just the,
well now like Swanson did with the
nervous system,
I lost,
I was so happy when I found this paper
because he did exactly with the nervous
system what piaget did with children.
He showed how the nervous system builds
itself from the bottom up.
And so Swanson lays right on top of
piaget.
It's lovely.
And then the other thing that Swanson
does very,
very nicely as he elucidates a lot of
the Friday and presuppositions,
you know,
so Freud of course talk about the Ed and
the Ed is this,
it's sort of like the archaic brain in
some sense.
You know,
it's all where all your primal impulses
lurk and you know,
he called that one thing that in while
you might say,
well,
is there an IED in the brain?
And the answer is,
well,
vaguely,
the,
the brain does differ in terms of the,
of the age of it's sub components.
And as you go deeper into the brain and
closer to the spine,
the brain areas get,
find a genetically older and the more
Fila,
genetically older areas of the brain,
which are underneath the Cortex,
they have their own little circuits,
you know,
and there's some commonality between
them.
And they do govern primal.
I think of them as primal
subpersonalities.
It's,
I know we've talked about that before.
It's better than thinking about them as
drives or goals or anything like that.
Because not only do they,
do they,
uh,
they're,
they're like sets of associated
behaviors,
but they're not just that.
There are also ways of looking at the
world and ways of thinking about the
world.
So you know,
if you're angry,
it's not like you're,
you're being driven to use your fists.
That's not how it works.
What happens is that the angry
subpersonality comes out,
you know,
and it does a whole bunch of things.
You know,
it's got its own state of arousal.
It's characterized both by positive and
negative emotion,
which is something that's quite peculiar
about anger because it's both a
defensive reaction and an aggressive
forward moving behavior.
And it has a viewpoint,
like it's a biased viewpoint.
If you're angry with someone,
all you can see about them is how damn
irritating they are and how much they
need to be defeated,
you know,
roughly speaking.
And so it's a whole personality.
Now.
It's a one dimensional personality cause
all it's really,
God is anger and that's not enough to
solve every problem.
But you can't think about it as a drive.
Exactly.
Because it's also because it's not
deterministic.
You know,
it's even when you're angry,
you have a range of choices to make.
Now there are circumscribed by the fact
that you're angry,
you know,
but,
but it's best to think about it as a sub
personality.
I think you just get a lot farther that
way.
Now what Swanson did,
you know how Piaget talked about
children,
infants,
they start out with a few fundamental
reflexes,
right?
That they're sort of born with,
including the ability to use their mouth
and they're telling me as an
exploratory,
uh,
device,
and then they have certain reflexes that
they can manifest right away and then
they have the ability to modify those
reflexes.
And so as far as piaget was concerned,
that was enough to get the ball rolling.
It was sort of like the child was
booting up across time.
It's got some,
you know,
outside of the operating system,
you've got some bare processes in your
computer that get it started enough so
the operating system can turn on.
It sort of unfolds up into something
complex.
Well,
that's sort of what human beings do
across time.
They start out with these basic reflexes
that are simple movements and then they
learn how to modify the movements and
then they learn how to chain the
movements together.
And then they learn how to use the chain
movements as tools in some sense as
embodied tools to pursue,
to,
to allow these biologically determined
subpersonalities to operate in the world
with some chance of success.
Okay.
Now and you can,
you can layer that on to the nervous
system.
So partly what's happening when you get,
when you get these basic movements down,
the ones that are now automatic,
like your ability to grip the,
your ability to,
you know,
do this with your hands and all the,
all the basic sub routines you have with
your body.
Those are automatized.
They're made into little machines and a
lot of them run spinally.
So you know,
because what you think in some sense is
that if you're walking,
you're thinking about walking in some
way,
that's how you walk.
It's like that's not right.
What happens is you orient yourself to,
to a goal and in some sense you just
disinhibit the system that knows how to
walk and then it more or less does it
automatically and you know,
you direct it and you can modify what
it's doing if there's an error,
but you kind of know that,
right?
You drive to to school and you drive
somewhere you're familiar to,
you don't even even necessarily remember
the drive if you've done it 50 times.
It's cause you're basically in some
sense you just sequencing automated
behaviors and a good thing too because
if you didn't have those automated
expert behaviors at hand,
you,
you wouldn't know how to drive because
it's,
you're just not smart.
You know the time when you drive most
consciously is when you first learned
how to drive.
Well,
you don't want a conscious driver.
You want an unconscious expert driver
whose consciousness is monitoring the
world for anything unexpected.
That's what you want.
So,
and that's the case for almost
everything you do.
If you have to become conscious of what
you're doing,
the probability that you don't do it
very well,
it's really high.
And you know that because maybe you're
talking to someone happens when I'm
lecturing.
Sometimes you know,
if I'm not really on top of things,
I'll get self conscious.
And that's a terrible thing to have
happen when you lecture,
you know,
just makes you stumble.
If it's going well,
I know where I'm going and I'd have all
these little routines,
you know,
that our stories and things that I know
that they just automatically sequence.
All I have to do is point the lecture in
the right direction.
And you know,
the things that are logically associated
with,
uh,
with the,
the direction of the lecture will,
they'll come up there,
they're primed in some sense.
And so Swanson helped me understand the
functions of the lower part of the brain
quite well.
And then to map that on to piaget.
And one of the things he helped me
understand was just exactly how
sophisticated the lower parts of the
brain are.
The more automatic parts.
Now the behavior is used to believe that
or did believe and still believe to some
degree that a lot of your behavior is
reflexive.
And the radical behavior is the guys
from the 50s but more or less made the
case that even complex behavior among
animals is nothing but the chaining
together of automatic reflexes.
So it was deterministic chain of,
of reflexes.
Well you do have reflex actions,
you know,
so if you touch a hot stove,
you'll jerk your hand away and your
brain isn't involved in that.
It's just your spinal cord that's
involved in that.
Now your brain's involved when the pain
hits and maybe that's so that you
stopped doing it in the future,
but you're,
the conscious part of your brain is too
slow to get your hand away from the,
you know,
from the stove and time.
And so what's happening in your body in
some senses that you have these multiple
layers of neurological organization and
some of them are quite fixed there.
They're automatic deterministic systems
and those are things you really,
really practiced and that you could just
run as a routine.
And then above that are the,
are those things that you chained
together but they could be chained
together in different ways so they're
less automatized.
And then if you keep going up,
they get more and more complex and less
automatized until out the top,
which is where your consciousness is
roughly speaking,
you're,
you have to program what you're doing.
You know when you have to pay very
careful attention to how to go about
doing this because you don't have the
systems built into you.
So you know what that's like.
If you're trying to learn something new,
it takes a lot of energy and you really
have to pay a 10 pay attention.
And then once you start to get it,
you know,
well there's phase.
What really happens is those things you
don't have to think about anymore.
And thank God for that because you know,
first of all you can't think that much
cause you're a pretty limited capacity
process or in second,
the programming is quite difficult.
Okay.
So,
okay,
so let's see here.
What I've got.
Yeah,
that's what,
okay,
so if you look on the right there,
there's a little diagram that's a
hierarchical die or a little table
really.
And it's talking about the motor system.
Now the motor system is
what allows you to output action and
like you're out putting action at all
sorts of levels that you don't even
realize because you know,
you might think that that site is a
sensory activity,
for example,
but that there's a very tight
relationship between sensory activity
and motor activity.
So for example,
when you're looking at a scene,
even though you don't know what your
eyes are going like this,
and the reason they're going like that
is because if you held your eyes
absolutely still and you can actually
learn to do this,
if you hold your eyes absolutely still,
your vision will fade right out and you
won't see anything.
And it's because the little neuro,
the little,
uh,
retinal cells that are picking up the
light get exhausted.
And so then they stopped transmitting.
And so part of the reason you're zipping
your eyes back and forth is so that,
you know,
different parts of your,
I can process the scene and it doesn't
get exhausted.
And plus you're also looking around,
you know,
and you're looking at when things move,
you direct your attention to that.
Or if someone makes a gesture.
So you're actually kind of using your
eyes like tentacles,
you know,
to,
to check out the information that's
coated in the light and,
and even when you're here and that sort
of thing,
there's a fair bit of motor activity
associated with it.
You turn your head unconsciously and
there's all sorts of little motor
actions in your ear that also helps you
tune in.
And so those things are tightly
associated.
But roughly speaking,
the motor output is action.
And then Swanson shows that there are
these layers in the nervous system that
go from the spinal cord upward.
The first ones are the somatic motor
neuron pools and the second are
locomotor pattern generators in the
third are locomotor pattern initiators
and then the fourth r locomotor pattern
controllers to hire.
So,
and the way to kind of lay piaget on it
in some senses,
to think of the somatic motor neuron
pools as simple actions that can be
implemented automatically.
And then the locomotor pattern generator
has taken those simple actions and chain
them into relatively more complex
melodies of action.
So kinetic melodies and then the
locomotor pattern initiator,
more or less decides when those
Connecticut Maliki should be
implemented.
And even that can be unconscious.
And then so it's still at that level of
brain organization.
It's still more or less automatic even
stimulus response as a way to think
about it.
And then you go one level higher and
that's where you get the ability to
voluntarily use these automated things.
So I could show you an example of how
this works.
So this is called a ballistic movement.
So I'm going to take my hand and I'm
going to bring it down really fast,
right towards that edge.
Okay,
so
all right now.
So that's very fast movement.
Now,
one of the things that's cool about that
movement is that I don't have time.
Once that action starts,
it happens so fast that it's done.
By the time the,
the,
uh,
information about the action actually
gets to my brain.
So I actually,
once I let that go,
I can't control it.
What I basically am doing is
disinhibiting the motor control systems
that are already have established in my
psychophysiological being.
I'm disinhibiting one of those and then
it runs automatically.
And so that's what you're doing all the
time when you're,
when you're acting in life and it's,
it's kind of a neat,
I wrote a paper a while back with an
undergraduate student of who's who's a,
he was a pretty break character and we
got invited to do a paper.
I got invited to do a paper on free
will.
And so we were thinking about free will,
you know,
and it's very interesting to think about
freewill in relationship to these
hierarchies because it sort of goes like
this is that out there in the future
you've got free will,
but as the future moves towards the
present,
you don't like,
once it gets close enough to the
present,
you have to have initiated something
automatic that will happen.
And so I can give you an example.
People who play the piano very well,
they look ahead of where they're playing
in the music because they know how to do
this.
They don't have to think about it.
What they have to do is look ahead so
that the part of them that knows how to
do this gets ready to do it.
And all of you are experts in that way.
Likely all of those of you who drive,
you're also experts that way because
when you're driving,
where do you look?
If you're a good driver on the highway,
you look like at least half a second or
a second ahead.
Why?
Well,
because 50 feet ahead has already
happened,
right?
It's too close in time for you to do
anything about it.
So basically what you're doing is you're
looking at the road and then you're
disinhibiting sequences of action that
are the ones that are going to
correspond to what you want to do with
the road most,
most adequately.
And as you know,
the closer you get to executing one of
those motor behaviors,
the more automatic automated it is.
So by the time you manifest the action,
there's no free there at all.
But you are,
you said enough to be released in some
sense.
So I could say,
well,
this isn't,
there's no freewill in that.
But there was in deciding to do it at
that point.
So and so that's sort of how your auto
automaticity meets your freedom,
you know,
got to think about it as something
extending across time.
So,
okay,
so having established that,
then we're going to get into the,
the uh,
the more,
uh,
neurological localization a little bit.
So you might say,
well,
you collect all these patterns of
behavior and then you automate them into
routines.
I could give you an example.
So for a child,
you know,
when a child first comes,
when a child is first born,
do you tap on the cheek and we'll go
like this.
It's called a rooting reflex and it will
move its mouth and tongue.
Well,
what it's doing,
roughly speaking,
is searching for a nipple.
And if you just put your finger there,
then clamp onto that and start to suck.
And so the child comes out with that
ability and that's a reflex.
It's sort of built into the neurology.
But then when the child starts to
interact with the mother to actually
breastfeed,
well then that initial reflex has to be
modified quite substantially in the
context of the relationship with the
mother.
Because the bear reflex,
it's enough to get the thing going,
but it's not enough to make it work.
And so often mothers take a fair bit of
time to learn how to breastfeed,
but it's also because the baby is taking
a fair bit of time to learn how to do
it.
So they have to establish the dance that
goes with that.
And one of the things that's quite cool
about,
about that dance,
so to speak,
is there's been studies done of
depressed and non depressed mothers
interacting with their infants.
And so if you take a non depressed
mother interacting with their infant and
you just film them and then you speed up
the film,
you can see like the mothers,
the baby reacts and above the reaction,
the baby reacts and the mother reacts.
It's like a dance,
you know,
there's this continual flow of
information between the two of them.
And if the babies with a depressed
mother,
that doesn't happen.
It's Jerky and,
and discontinuous.
And so if you think about that,
you can see how the,
you know,
the dialectical interaction between the
mother and child is building up the
child's repertoire of,
of complex abilities within a social
context.
You know,
I mean,
I know I told you guys before the
roughly speaking that,
you know,
kids really get socialized to play with
each other,
you know,
between two and four.
But that's not exactly true because even
the lower level,
more automated and more primordial
reflex behaviors,
you know,
like,
like the ones that are associated with
breastfeeding,
even those developed under the
constraints of a,
of social guidelines.
So society's always there right from the
reflex level up.
But you know,
what happens when kids are between two
and four is they have to learn to
actually play.
They have to learn how to play complex
games with other children.
And so that's a whole,
that involves,
you know,
communication and negotiation had a
verbal level and,
and also with people their own age.
So you know,
it's continuous in some sense of
discontinuous.
And in another sense,
okay,
so anyways,
you might say,
well,
why do you bother straining all these
things together and well,
you think about the breastfeeding
issues,
well,
why does it baby bothered to learn how
to breastfeed?
Well,
that's pretty obvious,
isn't it?
I mean,
first of all,
if it doesn't,
then it doesn't live,
you know,
and,
and there's a bunch of reasons for that.
It's like one is obviously it's good not
going to be nourished properly,
although you know,
there are things you can do to
substitute for that.
Although still breastfeeding still seems
to be the best thing you can do for your
baby.
Um,
although you can work around it,
but fundamentally it seems to be the
best thing that you could do.
But then the babies also learning all
sorts of other things,
like it's got skin to skin contact and
it snuggling and it's being comforted
and it's doing eye gaze,
eye gaze,
and it's cooling and the mother's
imitating it and it's like,
there's just a lot of things going on
there.
And so the child is organizing all of
that partly to fulfill a basic
biological need,
which is post two needs both thirst and
hunger,
but it's also fulfilling its need for
play for example,
because children have a circuit for
place.
So you could say play as part of the ID.
It's a fundamental biological need.
The other thing children have to have is
skin to skin touch.
They'll die without it.
It's not optional.
You even see that in rats.
So if you take a rat pop away from its
mother and you feed it,
but you don't do anything with it,
it just dies.
It's,
it goes into opiate overdose,
roughly speaking,
it's gastrointestinal system shutdown
and then it dies.
And you can stop that from happening by
isolating it,
feeding it,
and then like massaging it with the
pencil,
with the eraser,
end of a pencil.
You can keep the rat pup alive.
And uh,
Jaak Panksepp was one of the people who
either discovered that over,
worked on it.
And that work was extended by Tiffany
Fields at,
uh,
in a hospital in Florida.
Some really brilliant work.
She was looking at Panksepp's work on
the necessity of tactile stimulation.
And uh,
she thought,
hey,
I bet we could try that with premature
babies cause you know,
if a baby's premature,
couple of things are problems.
I mean,
first of all,
at the end of the term pregnancies are
nuts when babies late on fat,
you know,
so they come out and they're sort of,
they've got some storage storage there
in case things don't get going very
well,
you know,
and they're gaining a lot of weight to
not last period of pregnancy.
So if they come up with premature then
they're really skinny.
And then what happens often is they
start to lose weight and that's not good
because they should be ramping up the
weight gain really quick.
Like a newborn baby.
They outgrew its closed at one week.
You know,
those things are there,
they're gaining weight quickly to do the
premature babies lose weight and you
know,
it's hard to keep them going.
They put them in an incubator,
they feed them.
But what tiffany feel dead was,
she had the nurses go in there,
you know,
with with gloves and massage the babies
for 10 minutes,
three times a day.
And those babies gained weight as fast
as babies that were still in utero and
you could still detect the differences
in their development six months later,
which in baby terms is like forever,
right?
I mean you change as much from zero
months to six months as you probably do
from six months to 20 years old.
It's such a radical transformation.
So,
okay.
The reason I'm telling you all this is
because you lay out these hierarchies of
behavior that are,
well an automatized had brought under
the control of social conditioning,
but you really do them in the service of
of well that's,
that's the question in the service of
we'll say biological necessity for the
sake of argument.
Well you have to eat and you have to
drink.
And so one of the,
one of the reasons you lay out the
hierarchy that's associated with
breastfeeding,
and so you can do that directly,
but also so that you can establish a
relationship so that not only are you
doing it directly this day,
but you're also going to do it,
you know,
tomorrow and the next day and the day
after that.
And so the hunger system is integrated
with these other systems of,
of biological constraint in some sense.
And they're trying to come up with an
answer to the continual problem.
So you have dedicated biological systems
that help you address problems that are
associated with your biological nature,
that are universal.
And those would be the things that Freud
would describe as the end.
So you can think of these hierarchies of
motor behavior,
which sort of develop into
subpersonalities as nested in some
sense,
inside motivational states.
So there's the motor behavior hierarchy
that use when you're angry,
there's a motor behavior hierarchy you
use when you're distressed.
And kids get very good at that,
you know,
so they'll cry,
which is a reflex.
But by the time they're about to,
they're pretty damn good at crying.
You know,
they've got a,
they've got a cry that sounds like
they're sad and upset when they're
really angry.
And so if you really listen,
you can hear the difference because a
baby angry baby sounds different than a
sad baby.
But if you don't listen to baby,
you'll have you think and it's sad,
no problem.
Then you'll feel sorry for it and go,
you know,
help it out.
Really,
it's just thinking up years,
you know?
So we know this partly because,
so let's say you've got a baby and it's
under nine months,
six months old,
and it's crying and it's critical to
think,
well what,
what should you do?
He'd go in there and he'd pick up the
baby and you comforted and you probably
do that pretty much nonstop when the
babies that young,
you know,
because they're so young,
they should really still be in uteral
there.
They're really young.
But by nine months that may be starting
to get smart.
And so it's about nine months when it
can visually recognize people that knows
and people it,
people here she doesn't know and so then
the babies in there and it's you know,
squawking a bit and so want some
attention and then someone walks in and
it's not the mother and the baby bursts
into terrorists and people think all
that baby's all sad because it's mother
didn't show up.
It's like it's not sad.
It's really irritated that the wrong
person showed up.
And you can tell that because people
have done facial coding of the baby's
expression and also it's skin tone and
an angry baby looks angry first of all
and it turns all red.
It's like it's really angry and you see
that behavior later too and temper
tantrums like a two year old.
That sounding a temper tantrum is just
having a fit of rage.
The rage system,
because there is a rage system is just
completely out of control.
It's just absolutely dominating their
behavior.
And you don't really want to encourage
that because the rage system should
start to be modulated by other systems
and other higher order control systems.
Not so much suppressed or repressed,
which is sort of how the Friday comes
with thing,
but integrated into more complex and
sophisticated modes of action so the
child can use its anger,
which is an extraordinary and useful
capacity,
you know,
because it allows you to defend yourself
so the child can learn to use that in a
sophisticated way so that they can solve
the problems that would lead to a range
attack without ever getting to the point
where it has to be enraged,
right?
That's a functional child.
It's not like it's learned to repress,
it's anger,
it's just that it gets along with
people.
It never has to get angry.
So now some kids learn to repress the
ranger because you know,
they're in a household where any
manifestation of anger is dealt with
very,
very harshly.
You know?
And maybe there's a rule that everyone
has to be nice to each other all of the
time,
you know,
or else sort of a paradoxical rule.
But anyways,
you can imagine now there's a lot of
these biological systems.
And so I want to show you some of their
instantiation here.
So let's look at this one.
So when you get up above the spinal
cord,
there's a little brain area I'll show
you about how big it is.
There it is.
So there's your brain,
the,
the top on part of a part on top.
That's the cerebral cortex.
That's the part that people are really
proud of it.
It's like,
Oh wow,
look at our cerebral cortex.
You don't,
it doesn't,
it have a lot of neurons.
And then in the middle there,
um,
there are older brain areas and find a
genetically old.
And then as you go down towards the
spinal cord,
they basically get older and older and
older and older.
So,
and more and more
critical to your development.
So the serotonin system,
we talked about it a little bit in
lobsters,
right?
Serotonin system is the thing that sort
of determines where a lobster is in the
dominance hierarchy determines whether
it stands like this or whether it stands
like this.
That's an old system.
And when your brain is developing in
Utero,
it's a serotonin system that guides its
development.
So that's how important it is.
It's sort of like the conductor of the
orchestra,
but it's also the thing that controls
the entire unfolding of the brain and it
comes from,
you know,
really,
really it's a really,
really archaic systems.
So in some sense you're,
you're,
you're being is controlled by these
things that are ancient beyond
comprehension,
you know.
Um,
anyways,
you looked at the hypothalamus,
you think,
wow,
that's not very big.
And uh,
yeah,
it's not,
but if you take a cat and you,
so cat green looks something like that,
if you take off all the stuff that's in
light orange and most of the top of the
stuff above the hypothalamus that's in
white,
just take all that out and it's a female
cat and it's in a cage.
You really can't tell the difference
between eight and a cap that has all the
rest of that brain.
Now there's some things that can't do.
It doesn't do very well if you take it
into a new situation cause it can't
learn more,
more important in some sense.
He can't remember.
So it's enough perpetual state of
everything happening for the very first
time,
but it's still capable of a lot of the
reactions that would be necessary in
order for you to stay alive.
So it can regulate its liquid intake,
can regulate its food intake,
it can react sexually.
It's capable of defensive aggression,
although it'll really fly into a rage.
And so it's kind of like a disinhibited
two year old in some sense,
you know,
and uh,
as long as you keep it in the cage and
provide it with food and water,
it's like the way it lives.
And it's hyper exploratory,
which I think is just weird beyond
belief.
It's like you take the brain off a cap
and then all it wants to do is explore,
which is not what you think at all.
It's like a cat with no brain is really
curious.
It just doesn't make sense.
But it does actually because the systems
that drive your exploratory urge are
rooted in a hypothalamus and they're
actually the same systems.
The it,
it's,
uh,
individual differences in the function
and sensitivity of those systems that
are in part associated with individual
differences and extroversion.
So extroverts,
a sort of hyper exploratory and social
situations,
whereas introverts aren't.
And the exploratory that that has its
origins in the hypothalamus runs on
dopamine,
roughly speaking,
and then it runs through the base of
your brain and then up into your,
up into your prefrontal cortex in
particular.
And it's also the system that responds
to cocaine and amphetamines and other
drugs that people liked to take because
they heightened positive emotion.
So,
so it's very ability at a very,
very low level in the brain that that
determines things like the differences
in extroverts and introverts.
So anyways,
it's this tiny little part of the brain
yet,
you know,
if that's all you have,
you can get along.
Not too bad.
Um,
so,
but that's also because it's tiny from
one level of analysis,
but it's really big from another,
you know,
I mean,
you can,
you can increase your resolution when
you're doing brain analysis all the way
down to the molecular level and still be
looking at the brain,
you know,
below the molecular level.
At the atomic level.
It's sort of,
well,
everything's made out of atoms,
but the brain is already there at a
molecular level and it's insanely
complicated at a molecular level.
And the hypothalamus is way bigger than
a molecule.
And so even though it's small compared
to the rest of our brain,
it's still a whopping big structure by
atomic standards.
And so there's a hell of a lot going on
down there.
And you notice the Hypothalamus,
you might say,
well,
is there such a,
he said,
is there such a thing as the ID?
Well,
yes,
no.
Is it in the brain?
Yes and no.
Really low resolution representation of
what's in the brain.
That's one way of thinking about it.
But then you might say,
well,
is there a hypothalamus?
And the answer to that is,
well,
yes and no because there's the
hypothalamic structure and you see it's
made out of a bunch of things that are
different.
And so you could say,
well should you even group those things
together?
Well,
the answer to that is it depends on why
you're grouping them together.
You know,
if it's useful for some purpose of
understanding or control to group them
together.
I mean they're,
they,
they are similar in the way that they
emerge in the course of brain
development and the roughly of the same
file or genetic age.
But there's lots of reasons to treat
them as the same.
And there's lots of reasons to treat
them as different.
It depends on what you're trying to do
anyways.
The hypothalamus has all these little
sub,
what,
what do you call it?
Substructures that are really in some
sense at the core of the sub
personalities that we talked about.
So for example,
um,
okay,
so this is,
this is Swanson again and he's showing
you this is a rat's brain from the
bottom and he showing you the layout of
the hypothalamus.
You see,
it's got all those different nuclei.
It doesn't look like one thing.
It looks like a bunch of things.
And so here he says the descending
paraventricular nucleus is involved in
the control of eating and drinking.
And that's shown in green.
So that's the thing that when you get
hungry or thirsty,
that's the thing that sort of turns on
you're hungry and thirsty.
Subpersonality and then the rest of the
cell groups play a major role in
controlling two classes of social
behaviors that his behavior was
involving interactions between animals
rep productive as the rand areas and
defensive the purplish areas.
So now what you can think is you have
all those little sub routines that were
talked about,
you know,
that are sort of at hand and ready to
go.
And then they're organized underneath
these major classes of motivation so
that you have to do something like eat.
And so they,
the,
it's like there's an eating robot in
you.
That's one way of thinking about it,
except it's smarter than not.
And it's alive and conscious.
You know,
these things are alive,
they're not machines and they're not
deterministic.
They're just sub,
they're partial.
You can pick up them as low resolution
personalities or unit dimensional
personalities.
Cause the only thing the eating system
really cares about is whether or not you
eat.
And the drinking system is the same
thing.
You know,
you see malfunctions sometimes when
people have these singular systems.
So you can develop a condition if you
have hypothalamic damage where you,
you'll drink yourself,
you'll drink water until you die and no
one can stop you.
You know,
they could lock you in a room away from
sinks and that would stop you.
But you'd be raging away inside trying
to claw through the door to get to the
damn water because you're so hyper
thirsty that if it's all that there is
left of you in some sense that if you're
allowed access to a tab,
you'll just drink and drink and drink
and drink and drink and drink and drink
until you drown.
And you know,
people can say,
Hey,
you've had enough water.
It's like forget that the hypothalamus
is a major league system and when push
comes to shove,
it's the thing that's in control.
And one of the ways of thinking about
the way that you organize your,
your life is that the hypothalamus
controls the major motivational systems
we just talked about those.
And so those are the things that people
would think about as drives,
although they're not drives,
they're too complicated to be drives.
And then there's other systems that come
up later that we'll also talk about that
or eat that govern emotion like anxiety
and uh,
and a different system that governs
pain.
Partly what you're trying to do as you
organize your life is to make sure those
systems stay shut off.
And then you think,
well,
I'm in control.
It's like,
well,
no,
you're not.
You just satisfied all of the things
that could take control from you.
And so now you have a modicum of choice.
You can,
and basically what you're doing,
we know of these things have had,
what they need is you're running around
and exploring,
you know,
and that's,
that's also another one of these
circuits because the hypothalamus,
as I already said,
governance,
exploration.
So a lot of,
see,
psychologists often get things backwards
and they ask silly questions.
Like,
why are people anxious?
That's a stupid question.
It's how people,
why are people ever calm?
That's a question because like,
why are you anxious?
Well,
hmm,
take up all the terrible things that can
happen to you and they will happen to
you even worse.
And there isn't anything you can do
about it.
It's like,
why aren't you quaking in your boots
just sitting there?
Well that's a mystery,
you know,
and then,
well,
you know,
here you are in your normal state.
It's like,
well no,
this is not a normal state.
People have been trying for,
okay,
7 million years as people to create a
situation.
So complex and comfortable that a couple
of hundred of you can sit here,
you know,
without having your hypothalamus driving
you towards something and actually just
listen to something for a few hours,
that's not normal.
That's so staggeringly abnormal that,
that,
you know,
it's a miracle that the typical person
like,
and,
and for most of human history,
it's like you are hungry man.
And that's not the same like you people,
but some of you have probably been
hungry in your life.
But I mean,
what's the longest standing?
Is there someone here who's gone without
food for more than one day?
Okay.
Has Anybody here gone without food for
more than a week?
Okay.
How about three days?
So like are you hungry?
No.
You know you're hungry when you haven't
had anything deep for 20 days,
then you were hungry,
you know,
so,
and the same goes for thirst and cold
and all the things that were just never
exposed to.
So,
you know,
we think p civilized people are all calm
and nice and easy to get along with.
It's like,
yeah,
well you know,
you have absolutely everything you need
all the time.
So,
and that makes you as easy to get along
with his,
any completely insane primate ever get.
So,
okay,
so the rent,
you might say,
well God,
if you can survive with just the
hypothalamus,
what good is the rest of the brain?
And the answer is,
well,
if you're thirsty,
oh,
let's say you're angry.
The hunger system is going to be able to
take care of that,
right?
So you're hungry,
okay,
that works.
You're angry,
But then you have another problem,
which is you're hungry now when you're
angry,
now perhaps you can move through those
states.
You watch that,
you'll see that in two year olds.
It's partly why they're so fun to be
around.
It's like,
first of all,
they're really excited.
They're running around playing and then
you know,
they trip and then they're crying like,
man.
And then you poke them and they laugh
and then they want something to eat and
then they fall asleep and you know,
you're just,
you're just running.
They're run by their hypothalamus and
it's really fun to see because they're
so alive and so enthusiastic and
spontaneous,
but they're completely clueless.
It's like you take one who throws his
creatures to the mall and leave it there
and it's like,
it's just not happy at all.
And the reason for that,
well,
it doesn't know how to sequence any of
its actions,
right?
It it,
it runs through the states of need,
but it isn't complicated enough to
figure out how to address those needs in
any consistent sense across multiple
environments.
In a social world,
you need the rest of your brain for
that.
And so,
and that again fits in with the
Piagetian idea is that what you're doing
is you're taking these micro
personalities that are basically
instantiated within the hypothalamus and
then you're organizing those into more
and more complex games and you need the
cortex to do that because the cortex is
partly what enables you just to think
about time,
you know,
because the hypothalamus is it,
so it's all right here and now thing
like the hypothalamic cat lives in the
present,
there's thought present and that's it.
No,
you probably get some sense of that.
Like there are one of the things that
happens to people if they take
amphetamines or if they take psychedelic
drugs,
is that some of the inhibitory control.
Some of them are complex control systems
that are critical shut down.
And so then they enter a state where
it's all now and you know the now just
comes at people in that state.
It's,
it's a transcendent experience.
But of course,
you know,
despite that you've not functional.
And so in some sense you trade that
transcended relationship with reality
for a narrow functionality.
And that's too bad didn't,
that's life.
But you know,
it's,
it's a,
it's a tradeoff.
So anyways,
you're organizing these sub
personalities and you're using your
cortex to do that because you know,
you don't just have to think about
eating.
You have to think about,
huh,
how am I going to get the food?
When is the food going to come?
How am I going to cook the food?
What about all the other people don't
want to eat?
How do we regulate that in our family?
And then how do we regulate that with
the fact that we also need to sleep and
we need to work and we need to get along
with other people and we need to have
something interesting to do.
And like it's ridiculously complicated
and it really doesn't,
there's no end to the complication
because
you know,
maybe you're just solving the problem
for you and then you're two or maybe
you're trying to work it out within your
family.
Well they have not sort of like the
crumb brothers,
they never get out of their family
because they just never come to an
arrangement that works well enough so
that they can,
you know,
in some sense move into the broader
world.
Then you solve the family problem with,
then you've got the like the tribe
problem and you know,
maybe you can solve that to some degree,
but then you have the broader political
problem.
It's like you don't,
there's an infinite number of problems
that crop up for you to solve.
So there's plenty for you to do with
your big Cortex,
you know?
And we've paid a big price for that
thing because once we discovered time,
no,
we could make a bargain with the future,
which is basically what you do when you
regulate your behavior.
You're making a bargain with the future.
You say to yourself,
if I forego so and so now,
then later,
oh it'll pay off.
And that's real useful.
You can conceptualize the future and you
can conceptualize the future as
something you can bargain with.
But there's a lot of cost to that.
One is you can't,
you don't get to do just what you want
right now.
Of course that socks,
it's partly why people drink alcohol,
you know,
because alcohol's disinhibiting it stops
you from thinking it's the actually
doesn't stop you from thinking about the
future.
By the way.
It stops you from caring about what you
think about the future and that's just
as good.
And so then you could go out and have
fun because fun is,
you know,
impulsive and often extremely dangerous
because the longterm consequences,
you know,
it can be really devastating,
but it's a real pain to keep yourself
controlled all the time,
you know,
cause you're for going direct reward
constantly.
You know,
I think it's part of the reason why
people in heavily industrialized complex
countries aren't necessarily happy.
It's like,
you know,
takes a lot of grinding away to keep all
the machinery that keeps all of this in
place going,
you know,
so you're not getting typhoid,
didn't,
you know,
tigers aren't tearing you apart,
but by the same token,
you have to be unbelievably disciplined
and ready to act constantly to keep
everything that's so complex around you
working.
And that's not necessarily fun.
So,
okay,
now let's look at something else.
Now you can tell me if I,
if I showed you this,
I hope I didn't show you this.
You see that?
Okay,
good.
Now some of you know this and so you
just don't say anything,
although you probably don't know this
specific version.
So you're going to,
if you've seen this sort of thing
before,
you're going to think you're smart while
you're watching it,
but it'll probably still trip you off.
I hope so.
Give me a sec here and all.
See if we can actually get some sound
out of this thing here.
The monkey business
count how many times the players wearing
white pass the ball?
The correct answer is 16.
Did you spot the gorilla
for people who haven't seen or heard
about a video like this before?
About half miss the gorilla.
If you knew about the gorilla,
you probably saw it,
but did you notice the curtain changing
color or the player on the black team
leaving the game?
You're comes the gorilla and there goes
a player and the curtain is changing
from red to gold.
What you're looking for a gorilla.
And that's the monkey.
Learn more about this illusion and the
original gorilla experiment.
The invisible gorilla.com.
Yeah,
so that's quite,
that's quite the illustration.
So
one of the questions you might ask is,
well,
okay,
first of all,
how many of you didn't see the gorilla?
Okay.
How many of you have seen this sort of
video before?
Okay,
so you knew about the damn brill of the
people who didn't know about the
gorilla.
How many people didn't see the gorilla?
Well,
some.
Okay,
fine.
How many of you got the other things?
Both of them.
Okay.
Wow.
So you get the point.
The point is,
and it's brilliant,
it's an insanely brilliant experiment.
Um,
you're blind to a ridiculous degree and
your visual system and your brain are
constantly coping with the fact that
you're blind,
you know,
and,
and you can kind of detect it to some
degree.
Like if you look at someone,
what you pay attention to,
the things that surround them,
you'll see that like,
so I'm looking at you,
I can't see your nose for sure.
It's gone.
I can't even see your face.
I can see your glasses.
I can't see any features in your face
goal.
Can you smile?
The one behind.
So,
well one of the things I've noticed when
doing this is that like if you look
here,
look at my finger,
but pay attention to my face.
It's really hard.
Cause normally when you pay attention,
you move your eyes to what you're paying
attention to.
Okay.
So here's what you might see.
The first thing you might see is that
you can't see my notes.
The second thing you might see is that
you can really see my eyes,
especially if they moved.
God,
it's so weird.
It's like all of a sudden these eyes
park.
Yeah.
So I'll try this too.
Okay,
so look at my,
my finger again.
So you can also see teeth.
Well,
why?
Well if you're looking here and there's
something there with eyes and teeth,
you should probably be able to see it.
Right?
And so what that basically means is
you've got this tiny little phobia,
which is right in the center of your
retina.
It's just densely packed with cells.
And then those cells transmit
information along the optic nerve and
they're just connected like mad to cells
in the visual cortex.
But you don't have that much room.
So you can't connect all of the cells in
your retina to 10,000 cells.
Like at the first level of connection,
you'd have to have a brain in this big,
you know,
and you don't,
so you,
you,
you get by and part of the way you get
by as you're always moving your eyes
around.
And so it looks like you can see
everything,
but you can't in fact out here,
like if I'm looking at you now,
I can tell him my hands were there.
Although if I didn't know they were
hands,
I probably couldn't figure it out.
They're there.
They're kind of blurry,
I would say.
And they're in black and white,
but I can't tell that,
you know.
So out here it's like who cares what
color it is?
So you just don't see the color,
but you don't know that you don't see
the color.
And then of course I can have my hands
here and then I put him here.
I can hardly see them and then they're
gone.
There are so gone,
it's like they don't even exist.
It's not even,
you know,
cause you'd think in some sense that
what was behind your head would be
black.
Like when you close your eyes,
that's nothing.
But no,
no.
What you can't see behind your head is
so not there that it isn't,
you know,
it's literally,
it isn't even not there.
That's all gone.
It is.
So,
okay.
So part of the way that your eyes work
is that the periphery is attached to
devices in some sense.
And some of them detect lines and some
of them detect movement.
You remember Jurassic Park don't move.
The dinosaur can't see you unless you
move.
It's like,
yeah,
frogs are like that and catch her like
that to some degree.
They can really see things move this
way.
Partly because their eyes are slid.
It makes it easier for them to see
things moving like this.
They're not so good at things moving
like this.
Well it's because they chase mice right
in my smooth most mice,
you know,
except for like ones that haul,
they moved this way.
And so cats are specialized for that.
And so you're also specialized to see
teeth and eyes because you want to know
if something's looking at you and you
want to know if it has teeth.
And so what that means in part is that
the surrounding tissue in your eyes
reports to some degree to your visual
Cortex,
which is what you use to actually have
conscious vision with.
But a lot of it just dumps down into
the,
some of the brain areas we haven't
talked about,
not necessarily directly down to the
hypothalamus.
So though I suspect it has inputs there,
I just don't know.
But your eyes talk to your spinal cord
directly so that you could see something
snake light.
For example in jump,
just like you're,
you jump.
If your hand touches a hot stove,
you don't even see the snake.
It's like snake jump.
And the reason for that is you waiting
around to see the snake.
It's like it's bitten you 15 times and
your dead.
So you can't wait around and see this,
oh look a snake and you jump.
It's like,
no,
that doesn't work.
So you're,
your body has conserved all these layers
of reflex and movement all the way up to
you know,
higher order,
voluntary movement because otherwise you
just wouldn't be fast enough when
something super fast happens and then
the way your eyes are built so your eyes
can tell your,
your body to jump if no vision,
right?
It's just pattern,
snake pattern jump pattern,
snake pattern,
retinal pattern,
optic nerve pattern,
brain pattern,
muscle pattern,
no vision,
no seeing cause you don't need to see
it.
You just have to do pattern and pattern
matching.
Right.
It's a weird way of thinking about it,
but it's not much different than the
touching.
You know,
you can feel the pattern,
you can build a three dimensional
representation of it.
You can really see well with your eyes.
Just like the idea of that blind people
can't see as a really dopey idea.
It can't see color and they're not very
good at detecting things in the
distance,
but they have a visual world.
It's just built out of things that don't
have color.
You know,
you,
you know perfectly well that that's the
case.
Cause I could hand you an object and you
could fiddle around with it behind your
back.
And after some fiddling around,
you know exactly what it looked like.
And you know,
you might pull it out here and say,
well I didn't know it was blue.
It's like,
yeah,
okay,
fair enough.
He didn't know it was blue but you still
saw it and you can get pretty God damn
good vision with your ears.
So there are kids who are blind who've
learned to echolocate.
So they go click,
click,
click.
They don't make that noise.
Exactly.
But they do click and they can detect
the clicks bouncing off of things.
And they can do that well enough,
not only to walk,
but some of them can actually ride
bikes.
It's like,
hey,
that's impressive math.
So,
so what's that?
Yeah,
there's one kid,
I saw a kid on youtube who was blind who
could shoot baskets.
Yeah.
Which is fine.
Hey God,
that's impressive.
Now,
but you know,
my point is,
is that,
you know,
a lot of the neural tissue is,
it'll take whatever input it gets.
And so if you're born blind,
you're,
your auditory systems will invade your
visual system and then you have twice as
much brain devoted to your hearing.
So,
and then you know,
you can use that quite effectively.
So,
all right.
So I think we're probably pretty much
all the time.
The one thing I want to tell you before
we go on to the next part though is
that,
so now we've sort of built up the idea
of these underlying motivational systems
and now you can kind of see how they
work.
So you might say to yourself,
why didn't you see the gorilla?
And the curtain and the person leaving.
It's really complicated.
Well,
the first answer is you did what I asked
and then you might ask,
well,
why?
Why did you do what I asked?
I mean,
you miss the damn gorilla,
right?
It's like,
obviously that wasn't a very good
decision.
So you think,
well,
why did you do what I asked?
And the answer would be,
well,
it's sort of like the milgram obedience
experiment,
except you know,
why don't we leverage lower level?
It's like we've got an agreement going
on here.
You guys are all very sophisticated and
complex game players.
You know,
otherwise you couldn't sit here
peacefully for an hour and a half.
So you're,
you're very well socialized,
all of you.
And so that means that you've organized
all your motivations into a hierarchy
and it's,
and that hierarchy is guiding your
behavior here.
It might be something like,
well,
we need to learn something.
And hypothetically you've come here and
you learn something and so you're
playing that out.
And then because that's the motivational
state that you're in.
When I asked you to do something,
you're just going to do it.
Well.
Then what's so cool is that as soon as
you decide to point your attention out
something,
what happens is what you see in the
world radically transforms.
You know?
So I say,
well,
count the basketballs and all of a
sudden all you can see or basketballs
and you think,
no,
I see I'm not blind.
It's like,
wow,
you're pretty damn blind.
And so that's partly how you can
understand how motivation is a
subpersonality.
Like it has its whole sets of
perceptions and values.
It's like all of a sudden I said,
you open a little motivated state.
It was a complicated one,
you know,
but it was just like,
here's the task.
And so you're all motivated.
You're going to do the task properly
for,
for God only knows how many reasons.
And then all of a sudden all that exists
in the world are basketballs.
Right?
And so that,
that's,
that's it's,
it's,
it's as if you're,
your goal directed attention has
transformed the phenomenology of the
world.
And that's something that's really cool
because one of the things that implies
is that
what you see of the world depends on
what you're aiming at.
And in a real sense that this isn't some
trivial sense.
It means like literally what you're
aiming at,
I'm going to count the basketballs.
It means,
well,
you're not noticing the gorillas.
So one of the things that you might ask
yourself in this apartment,
what the phenomenologists were on about
is what he Ayman had and what is it that
what you're aiming at allows you to see
and what is it that what you're aiming
at blinds you to?
And it blinds you to a lot more than it
allows you to see.
And so another thing that you can think
about is like if everything you see
makes you angry and bitter and
resentful,
then you might think,
well,
what exactly am I aiming at?
This making the world organizes itself
around me in that manner.
And that's,
you know,
that's very,
that would be a complex from a union
perspective,
a complex would do that.
So it's a set of values.
They're sort of economist,
they inhabit you.
It's a sub personality.
It's quite complex.
It's got something.
It's saving that you might not know even
what that is because you're acting it
out instead of understanding it and
because you're inside of it,
it lays the world out for you in a
particular way and it makes you,
it makes the world looked like it's
showing you that what you think is
right.
But it's just,
you know,
if you're,
what did they say to the man with a
hammer?
Everything looks like a nail.
Right?
And that's,
that's,
that's one of the things that's so damn
cool about that experiment.
It's like,
really?
I'm really that blind.
I could miss something that radical just
when I'm involved in some dopey task,
like counting basketballs,
it makes me so blind to that.
It's almost beyond comprehension.
Well,
so in some ways you,
you know,
you skipped between different states of
blindness,
lot of them are biologically motivated.
Then you turn those into a hierarchy and
that sort of your higher value system
and then that thing points you at
something and the whole world lays
itself out around that.
And the way it does is it divides the
world and do irrelevant things.
And so those would've been the curtains
in this particular example or the
gorilla or even a player in black lift
the game irrelevant because it didn't
interfere with you counting.
So what you look at makes most of the
world irrelevant.
It makes some things,
things that serve you and that makes you
feel positive emotion and it makes other
things,
things that get in your way and that's
what makes negative emotion.
And so you've got the hypothalamic
system that point you in biological
directions,
you organize those and then it's like as
you were approaching the thing,
you're aiming at the positive emotion
systems tell you when you're on track
and the negative emotion systems tell
you when something's interfering.
And those are actually different
neurological systems.
So they're not in the hypothalamus.
The positive emotion system is to some
degree,
but the negative emotion system,
not that evolved later.
And there's a couple of them.
There's one that produces pain,
we'll talk about it more.
And there's another one that produces
anxiety and so awesome.
Now you kind of understand the relation,
roughly the relationship between
motivation,
perception,
and emotion.
No,
they all act together and they're all
dependent in this weird way in on what
you're after,
so that you can think about that for 50
years and you won't get to the bottom of
it.
You know,
the Buddhists say that everything is
illusion,
Maya.
Right?
People live in illusion.
Why is what you're aiming at determines
what you see.
So anyways,
it's worth it.